I've run faster every year for 15 years since I'm 35.
If me, I have a huge heart
for tales of transformation,
And today's rendition of this theme
is just an absolute banger.
Courtesy of my guest Ken Rideout.
If you set some goals that are realistic,
and just progress towards those goals,
you can just keep progressively getting better.
We talk about his early years,
the opioid addiction that nearly cratered his life.
It's hard to talk about because it's mortifying.
How he beat the odds to get to Wall Street.
You're only limited by what you sing,
like if those people can do it, you can do this.
And as midlife Renaissance,
as one of the world's pre-eminent masters athletes,
killing it post 50, and racking up titles
at some of the planet's most prestigious road races.
I found his council to be both inspiring
as well as highly actionable.
So please hit that subscribe button,
and you're gonna wanna strap in,
because this one is a rollercoaster ride.
Rideout man, good to finally meet you.
It took a while to make this happen,
but I'm so excited to talk to you.
Oh, thank you for having me,
I'm so incredibly honored and humbled.
Thanks for coming out.
We're gonna get into the training and the mindset,
and all of it, but you've got an unbelievable backstory.
So do you mind stepping it back a little bit?
No, I'm happy to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So your upbringing is pretty unique,
and I think there's a lot to be mined, and discussed about,
like how those experiences kind of forged
how you think about sports, and mentality, et cetera today.
Yeah, when I was growing up to me,
all my heroes were athletes.
And it was like my parents were divorced,
so I lived with my mom and my stepfather.
My dad would come and get me a couple times a week
to go play youth hockey.
So I was like very competitive athlete as a kid,
played with a bunch of guys that played in the NHL,
Keith Tkachuk, the Saku brother, Shane McGuckin,
like legitimate NHL superstars that were my peers.
But then in high school they just got better, and I didn't.
And I was like, "Man, what, we're doing the same thing?
How are they getting so much better?"
But that was my outlet, and those were my heroes.
So I was big, big into sports,
and going through life like that,
it was two very different worlds,
when I would go with my dad to play hockey,
and then when I would be home,
we lived with my mother's mom, and her brother,
who was a lifelong heroin addict, so there was
like completely unstable household people junkies
around all the time, it was very uneasy.
Yeah, a lot of chaos, your parents got divorced.
So you had your dad, you had a stepdad.
And kind of as I gather sort of upper lower class,
or lower middle class type situation,
basically, like blue collar upbringing in Boston.
My only point of frame of reference for that
is whatever I see in movies, you know what I mean?
It's pretty accurate.
But I can imagine what that must have been like,
like the chaos of that, and then you like,
what I've seen is somebody who's been in recovery
for a long time is it's sort of that child of alcoholics,
you're driven to kind of create control amidst the chaos,
and sports was one thing that you could kind
of have domain over, that would be like your thing.
That's right, and I had such contempt
for drug addicts, and just like unethical people,
and just like the behavior that was going on around me.
I had no point of reference to know
that these people were effed up, but I knew that
I was not comfortable in this environment.
I knew I didn't belong there
to the point where my own family, and people around me
would be like, You think you're better than us?
You're arrogant.
And I, in my mind, I was like, yeah, I do.
I'm not supposed to be here, I'm not living like this,
this is constant chaos, like, I don't want this,
I want stability, and I want things in my life.
I don't wanna aspire to get approved for section eight.
I don't wanna aspire to get like an extra $100
in food stamps, you know what I mean?
Like my mother sending me to the store with food stamps
was mortifying, all I wanted to do was fit in with the kids
who had a stable family, and for reference,
I mean, there was families in the neighborhood
where the dad might have been a firefighter, or a mailman,
and the moms were homemakers, but to me those were like
the highly successful families.
So in my house it was like,
what perk are we gonna get approved for this month?
And again, I had no point of reference,
but I was like, come on, man, don't we wanna aspire
for more than this, this is embarrassing.
Like, I don't want anything for free.
And I had a paper out from as young as I could remember,
like getting up early, folding the newspapers,
delivering them in the snow, just because I was like
I wanna have things in my life.
Yeah, you gotta take care of your own shit, right?
Exactly.
And were you able to seek out mentors in your coaches,
or teachers, or anything like that?
Like how did you find parenting outside the house?
No, that's a good question.
I don't necessarily remember having mentors per se,
but when I was about 10 years old,
I may be getting the years off by a couple,
but I was about 10 years old,
and my brother had mental health issues in hindsight,
and then eventually became a heroin addict.
But we were like, I was 10, let's say he was nine,
and my mother had signed us up
for our first sleep away camp, but it was like welfare camp.
So we go downtown Boston, and we get on the school bus,
and it's like, Boston was a very racist, segregated place,
so it was like, maybe they were like 10 white kids,
and like 50 black kids, which is fine.
I'm painting a picture for you.
It was like an inner city like camp.
And it was intimidating.
So we get there and I was like,
I'm going to jail for two weeks.
I'm nervous, it's very unsettling.
So we get there, my brother is a maniac,
so he takes off running in in downtown,
they can't find him, so the school bus leaves without him.
So now I'm on my way to like prison camp.
And so I get there and it was a lot of sports involved.
It was like an all sports camp that happened to be the theme
for this two weeks.
So my mother eventually shows up like a day or two later.
And it's way up, maybe in Maine,
I don't even remember it was so,
but I just remembered distinctly them showing up,
and calling me into the camp counselor's office,
and they're like, "Hey, your mom's here."
I come in there, I'm like, "Oh, what the fuck?
I don't wanna be involved in this,
I just wanna be left alone,
I'm serving my sentence, leave me alone.
I'm doing my time, I'll stand on my head for two weeks.
It's supposed to be this uplifting, nourishing experience.
No, but it was like a two week vacation
for everyone's parents to get rid of their kids.
That's what it felt like.
So I get there, my mother's like,
"Hey, listen, he doesn't wanna be here,
your brother doesn't wanna be here,
you guys can all leave if you want.
And I was like, "Nah, I'll stay, I'm do my time."
I don't know why, even at a young age, I was like,
I'm not quit, I'm here, I'm already settled in,
I've got all my stuff locked up on the locking key,
I'm sleeping with the keys to my suitcase,
my hockey bag, which has my all my clothes,
with a lock on it, and the keys are in my pillow case
because soon as I got there, one of the kids said,
"Hey, let me get those converse you had on.
And I was like, "Yeah, no, you don't have my sneakers."
So then I'd put them in the bag, lock the bag,
take the pillows, take the keys,
put them in the pillow case.
So when they came and said,
"You're out, you're getting an early release."
I was like, "Nah, I'll just do my time here."
And I end up winning like camper of the year,
every single award you could win there.
Because I think that in hindsight,
the leaders must have recognized like,
oh, this kid has something different
than the other people here.
Like the birth of commitment, discipline, dedication,
seeing it through, and then being rewarded for that.
Probably cemented some kind of neural pathway for you.
Like, oh, this is how you make your way forward.
Yeah, I was like all I can do is like represent myself
the way I want people to view me,
and we'll get into it later.
So then having to deal with my own addiction issues
just brought everything full circle of like man.
But being back in high school, and then realizing
the NHL is probably not your path, where's your head at
in terms of what you think you're gonna do with your life?
Yeah, it was around this time
where I like really lost my way
is when I went to college, I played football and hockey
at Framingham state.
The week after I graduated high school,
I started my first like full-time summer job as a guard
in a maximum security prison.
And one of the coaches that I had played against
in high school kind of sought me out after the game,
and said, "What are you gonna do for work?"
He knew my dad, and he said,
"I've got a job for you at the prison."
And I was like, "Oh cool, man, I'm gonna be cutting grass
and stuff like maintenance."
I showed up there and they hands me
like basically police uniforms.
And they give us like a half a day of classroom training,
like look for this, they put a knife here,
I mean, it was like, this is insane.
This is day of training to be a prison guard?
I'm telling you, there's so much information coming,
I'm like, holy, I thought we were cutting grass
when I got here, now we're like guards in a prison?
I mean, I had known when I was a kid
my stepfather got sent to prison
which was fucking mortifying, as like fifth, sixth grader,
he was like, oh, he's going to prison.
What did he do?
Petty theft and crap, like I think credit card scams.
But I was just like, man, come on,
why is this happening to me?
You guys can't behave yourself,
I'm I'm gonna be outta here soon,
I was just mortified.
This is in like fifth or sixth grade, roughly.
So then around maybe ninth grade, he gets out of prison,
and he's a nice enough guy, he's just, he is what he is,
I'm not gonna like go scorch that on him.
He's nice enough.
He was doing the best he could I mean, my mother was crazy.
Everyone was in a bad situation, so he gets out of prison,
and like, hey, he's got a new job, and I'm like, okay, cool,
I could care less.
He's a janitor, all right, cool.
At your high school.
I was like, come on, stop, stop.
I was like, "Please you're joking with me, right?"
And they're like, "Nope."
The good news is you couldn't do anything
more embarrassing to me.
Did you get bullied for that?
I never really got bullied 'cause
I wasn't like a pushover, but I certainly like would imagine
that even if it wasn't true that people were talking me
behind my back, but there was a part of me too
that was like, I can't control the actions of other people.
I had had a brother who had been kicked out of every school,
gotten into fights, wasn't an athlete was just like
a bad kid, which was always constantly haunting me.
This was just another drop in the bucket of like,
come on man, which is part of the reason why I was like,
I gotta get outta here.
So you take this job as a prison guard?
Yeah, so I start working in the prison,
walk in there the first day, and this big Irish gangster
from the streets who I knew from the projects comes running,
and picks me up on his shoulder,
he's running around with me in the prison yard.
And I was thinking like, dude, come on, man, pull me down,
the other guards are watching.
And I didn't care about the inmates I was like,
I don't wanna the guards to think I'm like fraternizing
with the inmates first day.
But it was almost his way of saying like, no, no, no,
I'm letting everyone know you're with us like we know you.
So like this is a dangerous place, people should know that
you know people here, it's just like being an inmate.
If you go to prison, it's very segregated,
if you don't know the people in your race,
has being a street person, you're gonna have a problem,
'cause they're all gonna want to have a problem with you.
Right, like they're gonna protect you as opposed
to the other way around.
I mean, were you 17, 18 Years old?
Not necessarily protect but then.
I was 18 just outta high school.
I mean, I looked like I was probably 13.
It was crazy.
It wasn't as crazy in reality as it sounds now
as we sit here talking in Malibu, but at the time,
I grew up with most of these people.
I mean, these were the bad people, but I knew a lot of them.
So when I got there, it was kind of like,
Hey, what's on?
And what was the day to day experience
of working there like?
It was the opposite of what you think of with
as shushing redemption,
it was a very hostile, intimidating place.
If an inmate had a problem with you,
they'd punch you right in the face, they wouldn't hesitate,
they demanded respect within reason,
the same that I would demand from them is like,
you'd show mutual respect.
And it's always like imagine being a substitute teacher
at a high school full of fresh little kids,
and they're always testing you, and they're doing things,
you're not gonna really like come down hard on them,
but it's kind of like, we're getting close
to the line here of where.
And you can't back down?
No.
And you being this young kid going face to face
with guys, hardened criminals guys, much older than you.
But I always tell people just because you're in jail
being stupid doesn't make you tough.
There's tough people, there's tough people in Malibu,
there's tough people in the private schools,
public schools, prisons, tough is tough.
And that's the one thing I've learned over the years,
in terms of like kind of vacillate
in between these different worlds is that tough is tough.
You mess with the wrong person,
you're gonna have a long day ahead of you.
But yeah, the inmates, they weren't necessarily all tough,
but they were all pretty crazy.
Did you end up in violent altercations there at all?
Oh yeah, multiple times I got hit over the head
with a pillow case that had a weight
in it once, fractured my skull, an inmate said,
'If you didn't have that badge on,
I'd punch you right in your face."
I said, "Oh really?"
And I went to take the badge off, and he punched me right
in the face before I even put my hands on it.
(both laughs)
My God, how long did you work there?
Three summers, three or four summers.
But there was one incident where I was working there
with a friend of mine called Brendan Daley.
He he eventually became a singer called Spooky Daley,
and he's a director, and producer now real very successful.
But him and I were working in the like modular building,
which that's the main building, which has like cells,
like you would think,
and then there's like modular buildings,
which were more like dormitories.
So inmate came in, and some of the other inmates
would teasing them.
Again, it's not like a movie,
it's like a high school full of jerks.
And they're bullying kids, it's just like that.
So kid comes in, so they're teasing him, and telling him
they're gonna get him and stuff, and he's new.
And they send him down to the warden's office,
the warden of the dormitory,
so the guy, superintendent of the dorms.
And he calls me and Brendan now.
And we're like the like dopey summer help,
that they hired all these college kids
so that the full-time guys could take summer vacations,
and they wouldn't be short staffed.
So they call us down, and we go down there,
and the poor kid, he's a little bit older than me,
a little bit bigger than me and my friend, Brandon.
And he's in a position now where he's not gonna tell
on them, 'cause you're not gonna be a rat,
like that's gonna change the trajectory of your time.
You're gonna go to protective custody.
But he also is now in with the superintendent,
like everyone's gonna be watching
how this whole thing plays out.
So he's realizing, shit I gotta do something.
So to save face, he picks something up off the desk
and half heartedly says to the guy,
"I'll bash your head in with this."
So then he says to me and Brandon,
"Get this guy outta here."
So we handcuff him, and he's struggling,
and I'm like talking, and I'm like,
"Dude, will you cut the shit?"
Like, dude, stop, let's make this easy.
Now he's like, we're on him, and it's just like a movie.
He's like, "Oh, fuck you, don't hold me back."
I'm like, "Come on."
So we get down to isolation.
The superintendent of the whole prison comes down,
and they're all standing in isolation,
they put him in the cell, and they're like,
"Okay, take your clothes off, strip search."
They always strip search anyone anytime
they move from buildings.
And he says, " I'm not taking my clothes off."
And the guy says to me,
"Ken, get in there, and strip his clothes off."
And now we're like down in a dungeon
in this like fifties era, like bunker.
And I'm like, oh my God, I can't believe this is happened,
I'm in a cage match.
I go in, they closed the door,
and I'm like, "Take your clothes off."
And he just stood there for a second, I said,
"This is your last warning."
'Cause now I'm just like gonna go attack mode.
And he just finally takes his clothes off,
and It's like, oh thank you, Jesus.
And I got out of there.
And no one's coming in unless something goes down
one way or the other.
Oh no this kid's getting a beating,
either, I'm gonna beat him, or they're all gonna come in,
and beat him up.
And he's gonna like, if he's getting the better, I mean,
they're gonna get him, but still I'm still a normal person,
I don't wanna be in a death match in a prison.
But I use that story as an anecdote for life
because when you think about things that are scary,
or intimidating like training with someone,
or running a race that you're nervous about,
or any situation in life you're nervous about,
especially with running I always tell people this,
no one's gonna punch you in the face,
no one's gonna hurt you If you can't take anymore,
you can just stop whenever you want.
So when you think about that in relation to being
in really intimidating situations, running to me is like,
come on man, this is easy work.
You've said in the past that when you were starting
to really get into running, you kind of looked around,
and you saw a bunch of skinny guys and you're like,
I was a prison guard, how hard can this be?
I can out tough these guys.
Just 'cause they're skinny doesn't mean
they're not mentally tough.
You don't have to box.
I say to people all the time, like look at these guys
that like running dweebs, but I count myself in that group.
And I mean it with affection, I don't mean literally,
but it doesn't matter what the reality is,
it's what I tell myself.
So I tell myself, these guys are soft, they're wimps.
That's not the truth, I'm a rational person,
I know that this, like I just said,
there's tough people everywhere,
that the nerdiest looking guy might Jitsu your ass
into submission in three seconds.
But that doesn't matter, what matters is the story
that I'm telling myself, and I'm telling myself,
I'm 10 times tougher than everyone,
and until someone proves otherwise,
I think I can win the New York Marathon, the whole thing,.
Like I go in with the attitude of that.
Where does that confidence, that brashness come from?
Is that just built into you?
Is that born out of all of these experiences
that you had as a young person?
I think so, because at the corner of me,
I'm like super, super anxious, insecure, nervous,
just like anyone.
I have all those similar insecurities if not more so that
I wouldn't say I'm overcompensating because I'm not trying
to run from that, I know that that insecurity,
and that fear is there.
It's a tactic to overcome that insecurity.
Yeah, and I try to keep the fear in check,
but I never try to deny it because I tell people
all the time, like someone at one point,
the best fighters in the world, at some point they walked
into a gym for the first time, and was scared shirtless.
If you walk into a boxing gym, or a fighting gym,
and you don't have experience, and you're not scared,
or nervous, that's not normal.
And anyone who says anything different, I think is lying.
Well, they're crazy.
An important element of my training and racing,
and the stuff I do with endurance is to acknowledge that
yeah, I'm scared, I'm nervous,
and I may just be nervous in disappointing myself,
but I'm nervous and I'm scared.
But those feelings let me know that it's time to get dark.
And indeed, even when it's the Turkey trot.
100% Turkey trot coming for your neck.
I'm elbowing, forearm, shivering people on the start.
(both laughs)
Oh my God.
(upbeat music)
It's not surprising you somehow found
your way to Wall Street.
Yeah, so.
By hooker, by crook, not by academic pedigree.
No, and to be honest with you,
I can be very self deprecating,
and I'm aware of all my weaknesses
and the mistakes I've made, but there are things
that I've been proud of that I've accomplished
along the way.
And one of those things is going to New York,
and seeing that there was opportunity that kids were working
in finance, and making money and being successful,
same thing with running, I was like, these kids can do it?
They have fancier degrees that someone told them
about this earlier, but if I can just get
onto a trading desk, and get my foot in the door,
I can kill these guys, I can out hustle these guys,
I know I can.
And when it say it now, it seems crazy,
'cause it almost seems delusional.
At the time I had a sociology degree in Framingham State.
I was working with guys who had Ivy league undergrad,
Ivy league MBA, and now all of a sudden
we were on this same trading desk,
but I'll step back, and kind of explain to you
how I got to New York, and segued into that.
So I got my first job as like pharmaceutical sales job.
It was awful, but I lived in New York and I literally.
Everybody needs that thing that gets them to New York.
Once you're there, the window of possibility opens up.
So I get to New York, and I'm doing pharmaceutical sales,
and pharmaceutical sales is the biggest racket ever.
When I tell you I probably work 30 minutes a day,
that would be aggressive, it wasn't good for me,
I need structure.
And it was like, you're left to your own devices,
and I hated it.
You had to drop in on doctor's offices.
Exactly, drop sample samples, get them to sign.
So it just became an exercise in like dropping the samples,
getting the signatures, and taking off.
I had no direction, I knew I didn't wanna do this.
So I was working out at the gym,
and playing in a men's league hockey league
in Chelsea Piers, and one of the kids
who I happened to just play with on a pickup team
was a inter dealer broker.
So he was brokering institutional trades between the banks.
It was kind of like the bottom rank
of the like prestige ladder in finance.
Like inter dealer broker is kind of like the bottom rank
in terms of prestige, but you could make a lot of money,
millions and millions.
There were people getting fabulously wealthy doing it,
I always told people, this was a job, it wasn't a career.
You're only as good as the relationships
that you have with certain traders that were at banks
that eventually those guys went to hedge funds,
or asset managers, so there was constant turnover.
So I got onto the trading desk,
this is actually a funny story.
I got onto a trading desk as like the assistant,
and I was the assistant, so I was covering young guys
at Enron doing like next day power trades which were kind
of like a necessity for the senior traders
to do the bigger trades with your senior brokers.
So the junior people were talking to junior people at Enron.
The trade was like made $10 in commission,
but it was a necessary evil for the electricity traders
that the next day power had to flow,
so they had to trade that, balance their books,
and then if you did a good job there,
they would reward the senior people
with their like real trading.
So I was doing that, and there were like two
or three guys there just hazing me,
which was a whole new experience to me.
I was like, these guys are hazing me like I'm a nerd.
They're being abusive towards me, I was like,
I can't believe I'm allowing this to happen.
Little do they know like you are a prison guard hazing.
I was boxing for the New York Athletic Club,
I had a black guy every other day, they knew.
But they just like, it's just typical finance bro bullshit,
and they were like terrorizing me.
And one day the guy threw a dry eraser at me,
and I just slapped him in the face.
And I was like, we're not doing this anymore,
you got the wrong guy.
And they were like, you're fired.
I was like, oh my God, when I say I had no money,
I was literally making like 40 grand, but by the time
I paid my rent, my student loans, everything,
I was negative.
So this is so funny.
I called from a payphone, mind you, this is in like 96.
I called the kids at Enron I was like, dude,
I just got fired, I'm telling you what happened.
Coincidentally, the senior trader at Enron,
who was like the Gordon Gecko of commodities at the time
was from Martha's Vineyard.
And he heard the story and was like,
give me that kid's number.
So he calls me and he says, "Hey, I heard what happened,
call this guy at."
I didn't even know we had competitors in what I was doing,
but one of the competitors got in touch with me,
and was like, this was, let's say a Thursday,
he's like, "Can you start Monday?"
And I was like, "Start what?"
He's like, "Come work here on Monday."
I was like, "Okay, I was making 40 grand."
And the guy goes, "How's 80 grand."
I was like 80 grand?
That was more money than my dad made.
I was like, I'm rich.
That there was something about you slapping
that guy that appealed to him?
Oh, yeah.
This guy is a gunner.
Yeah, he was like, what happened?
And I told him, and he was like, stand by.
Then when I got there, he told the guy who hired me,
that's my broker, so he starts calling me
and saying, buy this, sell that to the guys on the desk.
It's like bad Fox in wall street
when Gordon Gecko starts giving them orders.
Yeah, I'm thing about that.
I'm thinking about the Jordan Bellfort origin story.
That's exactly what it was.
All of a sudden, when I tell you I was making 40 grand
within two or three months, they're like,
your new salary is 125.
Now keep in mind, they keep raising it,
but I'm probably making like three or $4 million
for the trading desk, but I just don't know enough
to even know what to ask for.
To me, it was like, I think they made a mistake, 125 grand,
did they know I'm an idiot?
Like they're crazy, so I started just grinding away.
And then eventually the guy who hired me there,
he went to Cantor Fitzgerald to run
their electricity business and said,
"Hey, come here, come work here."
And I said, "I have a contract, you signed it,
you know I can't leave.
We have a real contract."
And he is like, "Okay, go to London for a few months,
and then come back."
So I did, and while I was in London, 9/11 happened.
And all those people that I would've worked with
were on the top floor of the World Trade Center.
But then you went to Cantor after that?
No, no.
So you went to Cantor.
So you were employed by Cantor when 9/11 happened?
And I was going back and forth between London
and New York, I was about to leave for the airport
to go back to New York to work for a few days,
and 9/11 happens.
Yeah, it was crazy.
So obviously you knew a lot of those people.
Oh, a ton, I mean, I worked there a few days a week.
This is how crazy it was,
two years before I was making 40 grand, now I'm flying
the Concord back and forth from London to New York.
And every time I would be like,
I'm living someone else's fantasy, this can't be real.
Unbelievable.
What do the guys back home think?
I think initially people were like,
it's almost like a natural instinct to be like F that guy,
he thinks he's better than us, like crab's in a bucket.
They want you to succeed, but not really.
It's like, if you're half succeeding, if it's very visible
like you're playing in the NHL, they're all like
your biggest fans, they'll kill someone for you.
But if you're kind of just pulling away financially,
there's that crabs in the bucket thing of like,
they don't really wanna see you succeed too much.
Yeah, you're not all that.
Exactly.
And I would say that that has dissipated immensely
since I started doing the podcast with Teddy,
but we can get into that in a minute, but yeah,
when I was doing all this stuff, it was fun.
And of course, I wanted to like share
the wealth with everyone
I was always been maybe overly generous,
and I would always have friends fly down to Boston,
fly down to New York, we'd go to fights,
we'd go to sporting events, in hindsight,
it was all a bit too much, too soon.
And around that time was when I was like really suffering
from like fraud complex, or imposter syndrome,
and was super uncomfortable just with the way
things were going.
I say like the fear of having money and losing it
was 10 times worse than never having money.
That anxiety around not making mistakes
once I had had some financial success,
it was overbearing, and that environment working in finance
at that level was incredibly, incredibly stressful.
Like I said, the relationships
that you maintain dictated essentially your compensation,
and trying to maintain those relationships,
and be a good person without being like a complete ask kiss,
or like just constantly living and dying
with these interactions with other men and women,
it was just a lot of emotional stress
that I wasn't prepared to deal with.
Right, being so young,
and really being inexperienced in the workplace
to get thrown into that pressure cooker
with the imposter syndrome, and diluting yourself
with the belief that the money is gonna take care of all
of those feelings.
And so what happens, you end up compensating
in other unhealthy ways.
That's exactly right.
I wanna get into that, but before I forget,
I do want to ask about what it was like to return
to New York city after 9/11 being a Cantor employee.
I mean, it must have just been devastating.
It was devastating, but again, it wasn't like you had
these relationships with people
that were like lifelong friends or family,
it was like, we were almost like mercenaries together.
It's hard to explain if you've never been on a trading desk.
There were some people that you really like,
and there's some other people you really dislike.
And that's the one thing that I don't miss,
is having conflict with people.
Since I've worked for myself, and segued into the stuff
that I'm doing now that we can get into later,
it's like I've never felt more at peace,
and never had less conflict with people.
And that took a while to come to that.
It took a while to come to that realization
that that was what was going on,
but like going through rehab and recovery,
you kind of like realized these things
that you had never considered before,
but going back to New York after 9/11 happened,
yeah, it was traumatic.
I think some people who had some loose affiliation,
or knew people that were there, it hit them a lot harder,
and they held onto that trauma probably more than I did.
Whereas I was like, it is what it is.
I thank God I wasn't here, this is awful,
but I can't let it consume me,
this is the ups and downs of life.
But yeah, it was difficult.
I mean, we were in the building in London,
and on open calls to the New York.
We had like an open line of communication,
there wasn't video, but you had an open line.
There was a guy sitting next to me,
his brother and his dad were in the building.
This whole thing played out in slow motion.
It wasn't like, oh my God, the building's done.
It was like, oh, someone hit the buildings with,
what is that a Cessna?
Then the second one hits me like,
oh my God, I hope they can get out of there.
But never like, oh my God, this is this about to get ugly.
And then when the buildings fell down,
then it was like wheels off, chaos.
So you come back to New York.
Yes, I come back to New York back and forth,
and once that happened,
like there was no real office in New York
for 6 to 12 months.
So I was in new London working around the clock trying
to cover for that.
Were you with your wife already at this point?
No, nope, I was single at this point, thank God,
because I still had a lot of mistakes to make,
and start a lot of mistakes to make.
Well, let's get to that.
And pain to go through.
The imposter syndrome, too much money, too young,
of course drugs are gonna enter the picture.
Yeah, probably in college, as soon as I lost
that connection to sports,
I kinda lost a little bit of my identity there.
And everything kind of went downhill.
My relationship with my dad, which was good as a child,
but in hindsight, I think it was, the sports was as much
for him as it was for me.
My parents had me when they went 19 and 20,
my dad being 20, so I tell people all the time,
man, when I was 20, my dad was 40.
I'm 51 now, my oldest is 13.
Like if I had a 20 year old kid in the house,
I'm a monster, I'm like I need everything a certain way.
If I had a 21 year old kid in there where we can have it,
I'd be like, dude, what are you doing?
Like you have to be in at 10:00 PM.
Everyone has to be.
It puts it all in perspective a little bit.
You can have a little more compassion.
So I think when I stopped playing hockey,
like a lot of that, and I stopped playing sports,
a lot of that stuff started to like,
I didn't realize that it was
an emotional baggage for me,
that all of a sudden, I was like,
man, is that where all my value was tied up in the fact
that I was playing sports, and it gave him an outlet
to go and watch?
Maybe it did, maybe it didn't,
I don't wanna like go scorch earth on him per se.
But it massively affected the way I interact
with my own kids, with sports.
I have my own outlets,
I don't need to live vicariously through them.
I want them to be great, and I want them to be happy,
and yes, I'd love them to be Olympians,
and professional athletes, but I'm planning for them
to have a career in like being a good person,
and doing something reasonable.
When all that stuff happened, and my life started to change,
and I was now working in finance, high paced environment,
it's important to note that, and people say this all time,
that like money doesn't make you happy.
I know people who have never had money,
or want more would say, "Oh, this guy's crazy."
But I'm telling you as someone who's had, lost,
and made money, I did not feel one ounce happier
than I do today, than I than I've ever done.
Like there's no correlation for me.
You have different stressors.
There's different things that cause me anxiety,
and cause me to like not be as peaceful as I can be
that came with money.
And all I can tell you is if you are a happy person,
you'll be happy with money.
If you are an unhappy person,
you'll be unhappy with money.
You'll just be unhappy about different things.
And all I can tell you is I was incredibly poor.
And then I don't wanna say fabulously wealthy,
but I had enough money to do anything I wanted.
And I was not any more peaceful with myself.
Matter of fact, I became fucking addicted to drugs.
It's hard to talk about because it's mortifying.
For the longest time I would've said these people
are losers, get shit together, stop being such a loser.
And then in the background,
I was justifying my own horrible behavior.
And I think when you go through that,
it's hard to realize at the time what you're doing,
it's only in hindsight, and reflection,
and going through therapy and recovery to a certain extent
that you start to look back at these things
and like, why was I doing that?
When you're in it, when you're kind of in the storm,
it's hard to like have clarity, and recognize.
Of course, because you wanna be able to continue
to pursue it, so you tell yourself a certain story
about your relationship to the thing,
and you having your brother, who's a heroin addict.
I'm sure every fiber in your being was,
I'm not gonna be like him ,and whatever you were doing.
I mean, what was it, coke?
Like what was the thing?
No, to be honest, I did do coke, but that was never
a problem because after I did coke for like three
or four days, I'd be like suicidal, where I'm like,
I can't believe I did that again,
I just wasted a day in my life.
When you slip in, like I would do it
for three or four days.
No, no, I would do it like every weekend
for a couple years.
(both laughs)
But I realized quickly, like if I don't have a drink,
I would never think let's get some cocaine.
Soon as I had a drink, I was like,
that's the best idea you've had all day.
The alcohol opens the door.
But that to me, the high and low,
that the low was so low, that it was easy to eventually
be like, all right, I've kind of grown outgrown this,
but the opioids was the drug of choice,
that's where I found.
Did that start after a surgery?
Yeah, I had a small surgery on an ankle.
I don't even remember what it was about,
something with an ankle tendon,
but he gave me like seven Vicodin.
And I was like off to the races, as soon as I took it,
I was like, holy shit, I feel awesome.
I had surgery on my shoulder recently, and they gave me,
the woman made a video, the nurse, that was super friendly.
They were gonna give me a nerve blocker before the surgery.
And they were like,
"We're gonna use an ultrasound guided needle."
And they had given me a PRP injection two weeks before
to see if it would help, and they used
a ultrasound guided needle.
And he's like, yeah, just so we can see the needle,
and get it on the nerve with the PRP.
And it hurt, on a scale of one to 10, it was a 20,
I almost fainted, I was like,
"That's the most painful thing that's ever happened."
So when they said, we're gonna give you a nerve blocker
with this ultrasound needle I'm like,
"I can't, guys I can't, I'd rather not have
the nerve blocker."
And they're like, "Oh, let us give you something
in your IV."
So they give me the drug in the IV,
which I thought maybe like Xanax or something.
And all of a sudden I was like talking to the woman.
I'm like, "Oh my God, I feel unbelievable, what is this?"
And she was like, "Oh, that's fentanyl."
And I'm like, "I've never been so high, leave me here."
And she was videotaping me to send to my wife.
I said, "I've never been so happy, leave me here for an hour
before the surgery."
That's all I can describe 'cause if you look at that video,
that's how I felt when I tried the drugs,
I was like, this is awesome.
And then initially it starts out like
a couple evenings a week, oh, I'm just gonna watch TV,
take a Vicodin, I'm gonna be good.
Then that leads to like, I feel like shit the next morning.
I wonder if I take one in the morning,
if it will like kinda take the edge off,
get me through the day.
And that went from like, this all happened in the course
of like two weeks to like, I'm taking them like breakfast,
lunch, dinner, and then every day, soon as I get up, boom!
And then I would do that for a few months.
And then I would be like, okay, I'm done with this.
I'm gonna like white knuckle all this,
and go through withdrawals on my own in silence,
'cause I would never admit to be in such a loser.
And I would just suffer through
these withdrawals being sick.
And it just became a cycle for years of on, off, on, off.
And I'm very resourceful, so anywhere I went,
when I was in London, there was a doctor
that did doctor calls and he was alcoholic,
and I knew he was, and I just knew if I gave him 200
in cash, he would give me a prescription for anything.
And it was like literally the worst thing that ever happened
because that's what kept me in business
while I was in London, otherwise I didn't know enough people
to have strong connects there.
So I would've been eventually just gone through
the withdrawals had enough, once you have like,
I don't know if you've experienced this,
but after like 60, 90 days without substance,
it's very easy for your brain to get like reprogrammed
to like you don't even miss it anymore.
And then one day you're just like,
you know what would be a good idea?
It'd be fun to just get high one time.
Well, it wasn't that bad.
Yeah, and at one time we'll lead to like
a six months odyssey, and then I'd be like,
I can't believe I've done this again.
Right, and that and that went around,
just keep spinning around and on.
And that went on and on.
And I was a functioning addict, so no one knew except me.
And it was just, I think the-
You think no one knew?
That's a good question.
I bet some people knew.
No one has ever said to me,
I knew you were doing something ever.
But your moods had to be erratic.
I was so aware that I was on drugs, that I was like,
did my best to keep it in the control.
But I was a monster when I was on a trading desk.
I tell people all the time, I hated who I was,
it was an aggressive, aggressive place,
it was like an open outcry market.
Meaning if you all say, "Hey, I got a 10 bid."
And someone's like, "I'm at 20."
And then someone jumps off and he's like, "Sold at 10."
If two people do that at the same time,
it's like who gets the trade?
All of a sudden there's people screaming at each other,
and the customer's on everyone's phone.
So you have two phones to your ears,
you're screaming all these orders.
And what if we both scream you're done.
And then they're like, guys, let me know who did it.
And now it's like, fuck you, fuck you I'll kill you.
You know what it was like.
And I just was like, okay, I'm gonna be the biggest bully
amongst the bullies, or the biggest lion in the jungle.
It's insane way to make a living.
Insane, and there's people still doing that right now.
I'm sure there's people listening to this.
It's 2022, like isn't there a more efficient way
to take care of this kind of business?
Dude, there's so many protocols on top of that.
So that's like an open outcry commodities trading.
Bond trading, you'd be like, okay, I'm a 10 bid,
okay, I'm at 20.
Now these two people are engaged in a negotiation,
no one else can get involved.
So you would tell your client,
"Hey, they're 10 at 20 right now, buy those at 20."
I'm like, they're engaged, I gotta wait till they're done.
So you'll like sitting there quietly,
and this guy says like last look at 10.
And I'm like mine at 20.
And someone would be like, "You son of a bitch,
I was gonna buy those, I was spoofing them saying
my last look at 10."
There was just different protocols, and different products.
There was parts of it that were as were fun and exciting.
But doing that every day, 24/7,
it was too much for me I just.
Need a boost.
When I think back on it,
I have such bad thoughts, bad feelings.
Was not a good lifestyle for me.
So how'd you eventually get off
that merry-go-round?
When I was in London, I went to NA,
and just like did the whole thing, went through meetings,
and had some good time under my belt.
I met my wife, we got engaged, and then I started
to like fall off the wagon again.
And then really when we started to have kids,
and adopted my daughter that's was when I like the last time
where I was like, okay, this is like.
So it went out for a while.
Oh, a long time.
And believe me, it's a huge source of embarrassment,
but it's like, what am I gonna do?
Who's gonna be helped by me keeping this secret
to myself if I can help someone by sharing this story,
and saying, I think like you said,
"I see Ken, I don't wanna run with him,
he's so intimidating."
People have this impression of me from my online persona
that I don't even realize I'm given off.
People say to me, "You're inspiring and motivating."
And I'm like, I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just like posting random thoughts,
and my day to day activities,
which include keeping myself busy by exercising,
and spending time with my kids.
There's a lot of like mixed emotions with it
because yeah, I wasted a lot of time,
and if I just accept that, and let it fester,
it's not therapeutic to me.
And if I can help someone by saying,
"Hey, listen, this is what I did."
Maybe they know someone who's going through that,
and their comment might set the person on the right track.
Or maybe someone hears this and goes,
'You're right dude, there's so much life to be lived."
And look, I mean, I started getting competitive at 35,
and at 50, I won my first marathon.
I know it sounds crazy to people, but I'm like,
it's like fear, it's like being sober,
if you don't take the first step,
you're never gonna know what's at the top of the mountain.
And if you think climbing the mountain, you are getting
up there just so you can have that view and be like,
I did it, I won a marathon.
No, the climbing is the hard part.
When you get to the top, there'll be another mountain
in the distance I promise you.
If you win Olympic gold, you'll wanna win another one.
Well, listen, shame can't survive the light,
you said you're embarrassed by this.
There's nothing to be embarrassed about,
but the more that you share it, the less embarrassing it is,
and that shame dissipates,
because it is in service to others.
How many millions of people are walking
around popping opioids, and don't want people to know
about it I mean, untold.
Hundreds of thousands of people.
It's crazy, one thing that happened
that helped me massively was I was introduced
to a drug called Vivitrol,
and Vivitrol is an extended release blocker injection
of an opioid blocker, it's an intramuscular injection
once a month, and when you take that, you can't get high,
it blocks the receptors.
I know 'cause I tried, and you can't.
You're like a good addict, you're like,
"I could do an end run around this."
I'm the best at this, I know how to beat this.
But really that drug the changed everything for me
the difficult thing with the drug
is you have to be sober for a week before you can get it.
And withdrawing from opioids that first week,
it ain't for everyone, I think that's as hard
if not harder than winning a marathon.
If you can get through that,
if you can have the worst illness,
and if you can have COVID for a week,
and know that you can make it go away
just by taking another pill,
and suffer through it knowing that there's like something
that it will get better, that your chemicals.
I always had a rational view of it as like,
I know that I have fucked up my brain chemicals
by doing this, and it's gonna take a while for them to reset
in the way that I feel suicidal right now,
this is gonna dissipate, I know it will, I have blind faith.
That faith gets tested when you wake up at three
in the morning, sweating through
the frigging sheets, mattress, and then 10 minutes later,
you're freezing cold, you're like,
"Please God, make it stop."
And you know oh, you can make it stop whenever you're ready.
That to me is like.
It's a brain fuck.
Dude, that's what makes these drugs so scary
and dangerous, and I think that it's like in hindsight,
it was so easy to just go in and get a prescription
for drug, for a pain killers,
it's almost to the point where it's embarrassing,
there should be more education around doctors saying like,
"Yoh, you can't prescribe this shit willy-nilly to people."
If someone needs pain medicine refills after the first
like 30 days after surgery,
maybe reevaluate what's going on with them.
'Cause I had a massive shoulder surgery,
and it was like a few days were incredibly painful,
but eventually you're like, all right now
it's just uncomfortable, but it's not like I need fentanyl.
Yeah, yeah.
Well I think it is better, I hope it's better.
I think doctors are,
they have a better sense of this now
than they did even a couple years ago,
but there's millions of people addicted to these things.
It's a huge problem.
Yeah, it's a big problem, and unfortunately,
I wish I had never even tried these drugs
'cause I would be more than happy to not know
what I don't know, knowing that it's there is like.
Yeah, but you can look back on it as part
of what made you who you are too.
And now it puts you in a position where you're sitting
on a microphone a couple times a week.
And you can share about this stuff, and it's powerful.
Because so many people are out there suffering,
it gives them hope that there is a possibility,
like not only did you get sober,
you kind of completely recalibrated your life,
and you're doing things that I'm sure on some level,
you probably didn't even believe that you were capable of.
I can't believe I'm sitting here talking to you,
it's such an honor.
And I know it sounds crazy, but the fact that I'm like
in these social circles with my friend, Rob Moore,
and guys like John Joseph, and I'm friendly with Joe Rolan,
it doesn't even seem real to me, but at the same time
there's another part of me that's like,
yeah, of course I am, 'cause I'm trying to be a good person,
and do the right thing.
I was telling Rob, someone sent me a message on DM and said,
"How did you build this network?"
And I was like, dude, if you think you're networking,
you're already strike one, two and three.
Who the fuck is networking?
You're collecting relationships like assets.
I said, I'm just being myself.
I couldn't tell you how I have relationships
with certain people because I'm not trying
to consciously collect relationships.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better, and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed
my life so profoundly, and because I want everybody
to experience some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner.
Our affordable all in one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable, super delicious,
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RR Health at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code RR Health,
for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Where does the rebirth into athleticism start
to enter the picture here?
Right around the time I started to really take
my sobriety serious, and realize like
I was responsible for other people, I bought a bike.
I was running and boxing for the New York Athletic Club,
and I literally had some like pain in my knee,
something innocuous, and I was like, I'm gonna get a bike.
I see all these people riding bikes, it looks like fun.
And I bought a bike.
Literally, I was like mid-range bike,
rode it for like two weeks, brought it back, and I was like,
"Gimme the best bike in the house."
I was like hook, line, and sink,
or I had everything.
First ride I had, cut off t-shirt, gym shorts,
I did have bike shoes, but within like two weeks
I looked like I was ready to go on the tour.
I was just awed.
You were all in, you're that kind of guy though.
I Loved it.
I'm not surprised.
You're the guys who you've been riding five minutes,
but you got the top of the line across the board.
Yeah, yes, and that part of it, I always tell people
when they show up with really nice bikes,
I'm like, you better be good riding that bike
'cause people are gonna come for that when they see you,
with your Colnago, with Campy, everything I'm like.
So I wouldn't say I had like the fancy European bike,
but I had like, the best specialized, or felt bike like.
but I loved it, I rode.
And you're doing the Central Park loop,
and the kind of group ride that happens in the morning,
or the evening there?
Yes, I didn't do a ton of group riding.
I wasn't a huge fan of that like tight formation,
and I've crashed.
You're putting your life on the line.
100%, you can get really hurt.
Cruise around roller blades and stuff like that.
I mean, it's a derby, people are going down constantly.
Yeah, I've had multiple surgeries as a result
of bike crashes.
I crashed on Topanga canyon went to, oh no,
I thought I was with Rob,
but I was with another friend coming down Topanga,
screaming down, and I looked back,
and it was just one of those things
where you ever look back, and then you look back around,
and you're like, oh my God, I lost my bearings,
and now I'm not gonna make this turn right on Topanga
in the steep part, and I went down on my face, skidded,
I literally stopped underneath the bumper
of an oncoming car.
Dude, fire trucks, I went in an ambulance,
It was like all the skin was gone.
My ankle bone was exposed, my head was busted open.
Yeah, for people that don't know, I mean, Topanga,
it has some pretty steep sections when you're descending it,
And there's really no shoulder for most of it.
It's Zero.
And it's pretty busy depending upon time of day.
And the funny thing is, soon as I jumped up,
I'm burned up everywhere my back, all my clothes
are ripped off for the most part,
and I'm just bleeding everywhere, including my head.
So I jump up, and my business partner
who was with me, is the nicest guy, but he's like very,
he's not timid, but he's like not as aggressive as me.
So he's like, "Oh my God, oh my God."
And I'm like, "Dude, how bad is my back?
It's killing me."
He's like, "It's bad, it's bad."
And that kind snapped me out of it 'cause I was like,
dude, lie to me, tell me it's not that bad even if it is.
So anyway then the ambulance, fire trucks, everything came,
and took me out of there.
Yeah, I've had some serious wipe outs on my bike,
and my wife would be like, "Why do you keep doing this?"
I'm like, "That was an anomaly,
that's never gonna happen again."
It all starts in New York City,
New York City in the park.
And riding and running, and I entered duathlon
in Central Park, like a two mile run, 12 mile bike,
two mile run.
And let's say, I came in like 20th overall,
and very quickly I was like,
"Oh my God, I didn't even know what I was doing,
I bet you, I can win this."
And of course my wife, who I was dating at the time
was like, "You really think so?"
She was kind of somewhat interested,
but not like obsessed with it like I was.
And sure enough, I started to do little races,
the North Fork, sprint triathlon,
and doing little things here and there, picking up tons
of tidbits here and there, but keep mind,
I didn't even know how to swim when I started in triathlon.
And you're how old at this point?
I wanna say early to mid thirties,
maybe around 30, yeah, around 30 to 35.
And I went to the New York Athletic Club
where I was a member,
I knew how to swim if I fell off a boat,
I could go water skiing, but I wasn't a competitive swimmer.
So when I'd see guys like you swimming, I'd be like,
"Oh, how is this guy so much faster than me?"
It would drive me crazy 'cause it was so much technique.
'Cause I was like, I have good fitness,
how are they swimming circles around me?
Even the guys who are in terrible shape.
I got stories about swimming
at the New York Athletic Club.
Yeah, a strange place.
Back in the day.
So I would stand there.
It's a weird place.
Yeah, very, but I would stand there,
and I'd see someone like you, or Olympics swimmers,
like, I mean you name it, I've seen everyone there
Michael Phelps, everyone.
And I would see someone who looked good, and I'd be like,
"Hey buddy, do me a favor, will you?
Watch me swim down and back, and tell
me what I'm doing wrong."
Most people, if you ask for help are like,
"Yeah, all right, go for it."
And you pick up a tidbit here and there,
then you see the guy the next day I'm like,
"Hey, am I doing this right?"
So when people will send me DMs and be like,
how do I do this?
How do I do that?
I'm like, brother, if you really wanna do this,
you don't need to ask anyone else, everything's available,
you can find YouTube.
If you really wanna do it,
you don't need me to tell you, you need to just do it.
Get in the pool and start swimming.
It's like running, I just started running.
I didn't have a game plan, I was running 10 miles a day,
and I started to recognize that I have good fitness,
I bet I can win some races.
But back to the swimming, I was just trying so hard.
And I think that the people who were the regular swimmers
there at the time that I was swimming, they respected it.
They were like, "Oh, this guy wants to get better."
And then people wanna help you if you wanna help yourselves,
just like rehab, or recovery,
if you see someone who's trying hard,
and looks like they need help, but they're putting
in the work, and not asking for anything,
people started to try to help me,
and very quickly I got strong enough in the swim
that I could at least not be blown out the back.
So when I got on the bike in a non drafting race,
I could make up some work, and then do work on the run.
If I could swim a little bit better,
we can progress into it, but I eventually came in
like six to seventh that Ironman Wisconsin overall,
same at Ironman, 70.3, in Honu, in Kona,
the half Ironman.
And every time I was like, oh, all the time I lost
in the swim is the difference between winning
the overall and losing.
Swimming is tough though,
because if you don't learn it at a young age,
you can get up to a certain point.
It's like learning a language when you're young,
it just becomes so much harder when you're older.
And the guys who are just, they have that technique,
it's like the fitness is almost secondary.
If you have that efficient, smooth technique in the pool,
it's beautiful, and you can do countless hours of work
without damaging your body.
Well, it's all about efficiency,
and making the water work for you.
And people that don't kind of have that level of technique,
are fighting the water all the time.
Not only are they going way slower, they're expending twice
the amount of energy exactly, and in Ironman,
you just wanna be in contact with the group or whatever,
so it's about holding back as much as it is anything else.
So when you're getting out of the water,
you're fighting to be part of that.
And you're like tapped to some level,
and those guys are like,
"I'm good to go on the bike now."
No, that's exactly right.
And inevitably what would happen is I'd get on the bike,
and start trying to make it all up in the first
like 40 miles, and by the time I got off the bike,
I was like, I'm on death tour.
And you're doing this without any coaching,
or really any program, like you're just going out,
I'm gonna run 10 miles every day.
Like that's not exactly like the best strategy
for getting these goals done.
Are you going online and saying,
well, here's how you prepare for an Ironman,
should look like this, or are you just trying
to do it the Ken way.
A combination of both, but I would argue that
with the running the 10 miles a day,
I'd argue that that does work.
How many people are actually gonna do that?
Like that's all I did, and I started running really fast.
No days off?
When I lived out here, the only time I would take
a day off was to do like a 50 to 100 mile bike ride
with Rob Moore.
So I'd do my long run on Saturday,
a long bike ride on Sunday typically, or vice versa.
But with the Ironman, I eventually hired Jimmy Riccitello,
who's the head ref at Ironman, and a really nice guy,
and he helped me really get ready.
That's a legend.
Yeah.
So in 2012, so I'm doing all these little races,
and I'm getting better, and I'm learning things here
and there, and I'm trying to pick up things from everyone.
And in 2012, I qualified for Kona and Ironman, New York.
And to me, I had achieved like a dream that I didn't have
it for years, but when I saw Ironman on TV, I was like,
that is unbelievable, wow, that looks so compelling,
it's impossible to do, but wow.
If those people can do it, why can't I, why not me?
I had always had the kind of an attitude of like,
I don't know that I can do that,
what these other people are doing.
And that was really the first time where I was like,
"No, dude, you are only limited by what you think.
Like, if those people can do it, you can do this."
And I convinced myself, I could do it, and I did,
and I qualified with a roll down spot in New York.
For those who don't know, there's a certain amount
of age group spots at each Ironman race,
and Ironman, New York, because it was the inaugural race,
they had a couple extra spots,
and let's say there's 10 spots,
and if someone of the 10 doesn't take their spot,
it rolls to the next to the 11th place finisher
in that age group.
So I got a roll down spot in New York, and I qualified,
now, I like, "Yes, we're going to Hawaii."
I had two little kids, my two little babies,
and me and my wife, and we rented a house on Ali'i Drive.
I was like, "I'm going to the Olympics."
I was like, "Man, I did it."
I was on a high, and I get there, and it's just like
you would imagine my equivalent of the Olympic village,
it was like all the like triathlon nerds, myself included,
where all like everyone's running around, happy to be there,
it's like such a culty place.
And everyone's crazy fit, everywhere you look.
You're like crazy guys looks a lot fitter than I look.
Compression socks, veins everywhere.
So we get there and same thing, swim, I suffer through it,
get on the bike, start working way too hard,
full of irrational exuberance, and sure enough,
I get off the bike and I'm like, oh my God, I'm crippled.
I can barely move.
And my wife's at like mile three on Ali'i Drive,
and I'm like hobbling running down, and I mean,
I feel terrible, and I see her and she's videotaping,
and it's almost like with tears in my eyes,
I'm giving her the like throat cut sign, like cut, cut,
like a director, like don't film me.
And as soon as I got there, I'm like, I can't do it,
I'm stepping off, I'm gonna walk back to the transitionary,
I'm not in a good spot physically.
And I almost had this mentality of like,
almost like a professional, like, wow,
if I'm not gonna be in the money,
like I told myself every story under the sun
to justify quitting,
I'm not gonna be in the top of my age group,
I'm not gonna do this, I'm not,
like basically, I was just a quitter.
I just packed it in like oh, I'm so disgusted.
Even in hindsight thinking about it now makes me mad,
but I did, I just quit, and I had no excuse
other than I was hurting.
It was such a letdown, I went from the highest high
in terms of like my personal satisfaction with myself,
to like really depressed.
Like, oh man, I am, I just felt
so ashamed isn't the right word, but it was almost
like a level of shame internally.
And my wife had been super supportive of me training
for this 'cause you know it takes like a ton of time.
Unbelievable amount time.
I've got two babies, she's like, "What are you doing?"
After this we're done.
Yeah, exactly.
And I was like, yeah, we had like a deal,
she had like written up a contract like you agree
that I'll support you to a contract.
She wrote you a contract?
I think she wrote it for the second one.
Good for her.
But my wife is like, when it comes to like being
a good partner, and a mom, she's world class,
she's the world record holder,
she's as good as anyone I've ever seen.
She knows, she's awesome.
And she was supportive just like I was her fifth child,
which is like what it feels like most of the time,
'cause she's the one that has like the rational brain
when I get irrational and emotional.
So I said afterwards, we're sitting there,
and I'm like so depressed, I might even have been crying,
and I was like, "I know I can do better than that."
She's like, "If it's that important, do it next year,
just do it again, and you know,
now you have to qualify again.
It's not just like, oh, just sign up next year."
So I was like, "Really?"
And she was like, "If it's that important you do it."
And I was like, "I'm gonna do everything
in my power to win."
And I qualified at Ironman either Whistler or Wisconsin,
Whistler, and went back and did like a 9:39.
And I was so proud of myself.
I was like, that's a respectable time, man.
I would've liked to have been on the 9:30,
but I was like, yes, I did it.
And yeah, she supported everything through that.
Then she said, "Let me draw your attention
to section six clause A."
(Ken laughs)
Yep, pretty much.
And then like any addict, I couldn't stop this addiction
to endurance sports in triathlon.
And I did go back to Kona one more time in 2016,
when I moved out here, I qualified at Wisconsin,
which is the one that I could have won that if I had swam,
I didn't, we had had our fourth child, and I just was like,
I'm not even gonna swim, I'm not gonna swim.
To save five minutes it's gonna take me like two hours,
three times a week, I'll just take the 1:10,
which is what I swam, and then I rode like a 4:58,
and ran a 3:15, and finished like seventh overall.
Won my age group, and maybe sixth,
and went back to Kona in 16, ad I was like,
oh, I'm gonna get him, I'm gonna like win my age group,
or be in the money in 16.
And I got pneumonia like three weeks before the race,
and went back, and walked the entire marathon.
But after having quit in 13, and then gone back there,
I was like, I know I'm not coming back here unless,
so I got on the run, and I was just suffering I was like,
that's okay, I'll just walk.
I'm not gonna disrespect myself, or the race.
And I just walked and I made it like a click
either right over under 11 hours,
but right before the sun went down,
I was like, oh, thank God, I'm racing the sun.
And it was around that time that I started
to just do more running just because of a lack of time.
And that's when I started the 10 miles
every day around 2016.
Right.
(upbeat music)
You got really far just on grit, and determination,
and persistence like here's what I'm doing in kind
of a bullheaded way, like I don't need to really look
and see what else anybody's doing,
I know me, and I can figure this out.
But in order to really level up and achieve your goals,
you did reach that point where you're like,
hey, I need to bring somebody in.
And I think there's a lot of people who are watching,
or listening to this, who can relate to that
like I can't afford a coach, or I have a job,
and like I just go out, and do what I can do every day.
So I think it would be cool to share a little bit about
like what you've learned through those relationships
that could be helpful to the amateur athletes out there.
I would say this, if you are spending time,
and effort doing this stuff, I would argue that
you can't afford not to have a coach,
because everyone has so much time, and money,
and effort invested into their result,
if it's something important to them.
If you're just doing weekend races and trying to finish,
like maybe you don't need a coach,
but if you wanna be competitive, even if it's with yourself.
Your approach, you're an amateur,
but you train like a professional now.
Do you treat it like any professional athlete would?
Oh, if my wife tells me like, what are you doing?
We're going ski, we were in Aspen, we're skiing,
I'm like, yeah, I gotta work for us.
She's like, "What do you mean?"
I'm like, "well, this is my job."
Like this is part of who I am.
I need this to feel, I need this to start my day.
And I would say about a coach like if it's really important
to you, and it could be just you racing yourself,
maybe you wanna break 3:30, whatever it is,
if you think that you've invested this kind of time
and effort to hire a coach, I mean, there's coaches,
and it's super expensive, and there's tons of online assets.
But one of the things that I found in working
with real coaches, and guys who are very knowledgeable,
especially like Jimmy Riccitello,
when it comes to triathlon and cycling, I mean,
his son is like now a pro tour rider,
I think he might even be on a pro tour team in Europe,
Jimmy gave me my introduction to like real structure,
and real accountability more than anything.
Is like, I could look at online plans,
but if there's no one kind of monitoring it,
even if it's just not that I was trying to impress someone,
but just knowing that-
He's gonna look at it.
You don't wanna let him down.
I viewed Mario and Jimmy, and I talked to Mario
all the time Jimmy, I talked occasionally,
but not since I'm not doing triathlon much less.
But when I talk to Mario, I tell him,
"Dude, we're partners, we're teammates, I'm representing you
when I'm out there, I believe this.
I believe I only have one teammate in running,
it's me and you, it's me, or with Mario."
And I'm like, "You write the formula,
you write the prescription,
and I'm gonna take the medicine."
So he gives structure, and like you said,
I was running 10 miles a day, and when I got to 2:33,
I couldn't break through, I went back to CIM,
and ran like 2:35.
But running a 1:10 in the first half,
probably wasn't very conducive to running fast
for the second half, considering that was like three minutes
faster than my half marathon PR.
The year after I ran 2:28, I was like,
oh, I bet I can run 2:26.
So I ran 1:10 first half, and it blew myself outta
the water with three or four miles to go.
But when it comes to the running with Mario,
it's like he writes the plan, and I follow it
like a roadmap.
Meaning if there's traffic on one direction,
I might take a slightly different, but ultimately I'm trying
to get to the same place.
So the coaching is like a rough outline,
it's not an exact science.
Like today, there was a track workout,
but obviously I was got in late, didn't sleep great,
So I said, I'm gonna do that tomorrow on the beach.
And I just make changes here and there,
but it's literally like those kind of things
we don't even have to talk about because he sees everything
that I'm doing in real time, and everyone can,
I post everything on Strava.
And part of that is for accountability too.
It's like this is what I do.
I get a lot out of it, that accountability provides me
with structure, and a sense of accomplishment
to start the day, it's like the military guy who was given
the commencement address, and he said,
"Start the day by making your bed,
you have one win already."
That's how I view the run is, if nothing else happens today,
I've taken care of my most important asset,
my mental and physical health.
It's more important to me than everything it has to be.
I can't be my best self with my children, or my wife,
and I'm useless to anyone if I'm not healthy.
And part of this exercise every day in this 10 mile therapy,
is as much mental health as it is physical.
It makes me feel good, it is my antidepressant,
when I go through periods of not being able to do it,
like when I had the shoulder surgery, I had a few days
of real depression,
I don't wanna say suicidal thoughts,
but certainly like suicidal ideation of like,
would I be better off just not doing this?
Do I wanna be here?
And I know when I say it it sounds irrational,
and I reflect on it, it sounds crazy,
but I can't deny that these are the thoughts that enter
my head when I'm not holding myself accountable,
and maybe it's a blessing, maybe it's a curse,
but this is just the reality of my life is I just,
maybe from the mistakes I've made,
and the things that I've been through,
like this it's just what I need.
I'm not opposed to hearing professional takes.
So I'm like, you should try this, this, this.
I'm not close-minded, but right now that's my state of mind,
is I need this.
Yeah, in hearing you share that,
I certainly relate to that deeply, but at the same time,
I also can't help but think like you're holding
onto it so tightly.
Like on some level like is it self-flagellation
like you're doing penance, like you're punishing yourself
because there's a sense of undeservedness,
or you're not worthy until, or unless you get that in.
And there's gotta be moments when those priorities come
into conflict when your workout is at odds
with something that you need to do with your kids,
and you have to make those decisions around
where you're gonna invest your time, and your energy.
When there's real conflict, I will say like,
I will make the amendments, and adjustments on the fly.
Like if someone had an eight o'clock little league game,
and it was like, there's so many kids,
we divide and conquer, but if there was one that we all have
to be at, like I'll go to the game,
and then maybe I'll run home, or I'll do something,
but I'll always like-
Find a way to work it out.
I try to find that balance, but you are not far off there
in your assessment there.
There's definitely like some things that I know
that I need to address. I don't profess
to have all the answers, or to be doing everything right,
I know that there's things I need to improve.
I think there's a gift in there
if you're willing to explore it.
I'm not a professional, I don't know what it's about,
I mean, perhaps it has something to do with a sense
of guilt, like you have this amazing life,
and this is just the payment that you have to make
on a daily basis to earn, or deserve the life that you have.
I don't know, and there's certainly nothing wrong
with being competitive, and hard driving,
and you're accomplishing all of these things,
and then you share it so openly with people,
and that's of service.
And so I don't mean to malign any of it,
I just think it's interesting and curious,
and I think there is like some kind
of like growth opportunity for you there.
You're not maligning me, and I don't feel
at all uncomfortable, I think part of the benefit
of doing something like this is being able to share
my truths, and my reality with people,
and hoping that somehow I can improve the quality
of my own life through sharing my stories.
And you're 100% right, I know that this isn't necessarily
like the greatest success story in history.
I know that there's things that I could,
and should be doing better, and it's a constant struggle,
but compared to where I've been, and what I've been through,
right now, this is what's keeping me on the path I'm on,
but I would fully agree with you that there is like work
to be done here, that I shouldn't have to feel like
I have to do this, and unconsciously-
What happens if suddenly something happens,
and you can't do this?
Like, how are you gonna be okay with yourself?
How are you gonna find meaning, and purpose,
and be happy, and productive?
Be an ultra swimmer.
(both laughs)
Find another challenge.
And that brings up that kind of other piece here,
and you mentioned it earlier,
like this addiction to endurance sports.
And I know as somebody who's in recovery,
like I get it a lot, like, oh, you transferred one addiction
for the other.
And I don't know how you answer that question.
I'm sure it gets thrown in your direction.
Like I have to think about that, and I think on some level,
I have to recognize that there's truth in that,
like I wanna say, no, you don't understand addiction
was trying to destroy my life, these efforts make
my life better, they're completely different,
but of course there's similarities and overlap.
And if I'm not rigorous, that relationship
can get out of whack, and the other things,
the other buckets in my life that are important will suffer.
And so I'm always like trying to maintain
a healthy relationship with all of these things,
and I'm not always successful at that,
but like how do you think about that as somebody
who's in recovery, and is so driven, and so ambitious
in these goals that you're seeking at age 51?
You hit the nail right on the head.
And as you are saying that, I'm reflecting
on my own decisions, and wondering if in fact that
there's a lot more deep work that needs to be done.
And this endurance stuff in essence is prolonging me
from having to do the other work that I need to do
to kinda deal with the psychological
and emotional issues that I have,
because like I said, I don't profess to have all
the answers, and yeah, I've convinced myself
that this is the best, it's all going right.
But in my mind I know that there's things
that can be better for sure.
And I think that really the person who probably takes
the most amount of shit for this is probably my wife,
because it makes me emotional to even think about
because she is my biggest advocate and supporter,
and at times she's getting the worst of me,
and it's something that for sure
again, these conversations are all part of the process,
and part of the therapy, and I hope that
if someone's listening to this, and relates to anything,
that they're getting that like life isn't Instagram,
like that's just a small snapshot of like a reality.
I think that more so than anyone
is my wife probably recognizes that is like,
yoh, there's a lot of things you can be doing better.
The good news is endurance sports
is a pretty great vehicle for personal growth,
and all that time spent alone in reflection
with an elevated heart rate.
I just know for myself is critical to my own mental health,
but also gives me that ability
to kind of like free associate,
and get a little bit more objective on the things
that I'm running away from, because it can be
an out of whack relationship with endurance sports
that teacher then becomes the escape hatch.
Like you can use it to run away from a bunch of stuff,
and shroud yourself with a victory lap or whatever,
and say, this is great, and I love it.
But when you're really honest with yourself,
you're like, yeah, but it's easier for me to go out,
and crush it than it is to deal with this other thing
that I really don't wanna deal with.
I will tell you that.
And that's true of all of us,
'cause growth never ends, there's always more layers.
I'll say this, that, yeah,
you hit on so many important topics, but on one hand,
like the endurance sports and the relationships
I've built have basically given me the life I've have.
I can't stress to the listeners enough like you have
to surround yourself with people that you admire
and respect, and this finding endurance sports,
and having success, there was a way for me to connect
with like-minded people that have changed my life.
My best friends in the world are from endurance sports.
I have so many deep relationship with people that I love
that if I hadn't been involved in this, but you're right,
there is a certain level of escape
by almost putting off work that I know needs to be done,
but I'm using the endurance as like a bit of an escape,
or a distraction from things that need to be addressed.
So, like I said, this all part of the therapy for me
is sharing these stories, and being so open, and honest
even at like my own detrimentive, my wife will be like,
"I can't believe you shared all that."
I'm like, "Ah, who even cares."
I'm like hopefully someone gets something out of it,
but in recovery, they'll tell you,
you're only as sick as the secrets you keep.
And I appreciate the honesty.
And as we're talking through
all these different challenges of life,
and I hope I'm doing a good job of kind of highlighting
like the race results speak for themselves,
anyone can see that.
But I hope that I'm representing to people that Instagram
isn't real life, that's just a small snapshot into like
what I wanna share as a still image.
But really, I hope that what comes through in this interview
is that like, no one is special, no one is unique.
Meaning we are all dealing with internal struggles.
And I hope that by sharing some of these things,
it lets people know like no matter what you've been through,
or what you're going through, you can still get better,
every day you get a chance to start over.
And it's easy to say this stuff, and it sounds cliche,
but the running is a perfect reflection of that is like,
I always post on Mondays like,
let's go, it's Monday, let's start this week.
But then when someone says it back to me, I'm like,
Hey, it's Monday, let's go.
I'm like every fucking day is Monday,
and every day is Saturday,
it's the same thing over and over.
But when someone says it to me, it has different context,
but I'm trying to motivate and to tell people like,
let's go no matter what's going on internally,
the one constant, and the one thing you can control
is what you do today.
So what I've been trying to do through the running
is use that as a coping mechanism to a certain extent
with all this internal noise that can get loud in my head
at times, and I don't wanna like use drugs to combat it.
And this for me has been the outlet that's helped.
But I would say to your earlier point,
and probably to my wife's like point for the last 20 years,
is like what I really need to do,
and what I've like committed to do with her is like,
I really need to like talk to someone on a regular basis,
and get comfortable with, that if the running wasn't there,
can I still have the same inner piece?
And that's to me is hopefully what people take away
from this is that, the running is just a piece.
I don't wanna belittle my accomplishments
when I say anyone can do this, anyone can just go out set
a goal, and set up out doing it in a workman like fashion.
It's just, there's no substitute for hard work,
you know the expression work works.
This stuff that I did like you was saying,
you just ran 10 miles a day.
Like I literally went from like a 3:20 marathon,
to a 2:33 marathon from running 10 miles a day
with no structure, no real training plan just knowing that,
huh, the more I run, the stronger I get at any distance.
You're also pretty humble about the whole thing
like you're in check with your humility.
You always say, like, "I'm no great athlete,
I got into this late, and I still don't really know
what I'm doing, and all that kind of stuff."
And I think that's really powerful because
your accomplishments are so obvious in this regard.
And to your point of like the internal struggles,
and the battles that we all have, and we all share,
it might be appropriate as we kind of start to wind
this thing down, to share a little bit more about
those mindset tools, or mantras, or practices,
that you've developed that have been effective,
or might be a catalyst for the person who's still
on the couch, or looking for that way forward
on a new trajectory.
Because you've made such radical changes in your life,
like how do you communicate that to somebody
who's on the precipice of making that breakthrough
to kind of give him the wind in the sales so to speak.
Yeah, the one thing that I will say,
I heard your interviews with David Goggins, I mean,
I've heard a lot of your areas, but one of the things
that he said that really resonated with me
that always comes back to my top of mind for me is
that like, this is what I do, this is just what I do.
When I get up to run, it's funny because
as you build some like mental toughness in callous
your mind a little bit to the reality that like
this is every day, it's like when you're going
through recovery, it's like,
how the am I gonna not drink for two weeks?
Like you don't have to, you only have to not drink
for the next hour, and then we'll deal with the next hour.
That's the running is like, you just have to set
a real goal, and if nothing else, and I think
it's almost easier later in life,
because I've made so many mistakes in my life,
and we all have, but today you can start doing
the right thing right now.
I always wanna be mindful of people's abilities
and capabilities and say,
you don't have to run 10 miles a day,
but if you've never run, maybe you're gonna start walking
one mile a day minimum, and set realistic goals.
Like, okay, I don't care, like how outta shape you are,
that's not that ambitious, if you have something wrong
with you, that's a different story.
But if you are healthy, start with walk in a mile,
maybe it's running a 5K if you are capable of that,
or a 10K, but be dependable to yourself,
it's shocking how much that can help you in other areas
of your life when you're dependable to yourself.
When you know, I know that if the shit hits the fan here,
I know I can count on myself to do the right thing
when the chips are down.
Left to my own devices, when things are fluffy and cool,
and it's easy to make mistakes, but if the chips are down,
and there's like something incredibly important happening,
like I know I can count on myself because if nothing else,
I've proven that to myself
and you have to believe it yourself.
So back to my point about David Goggins,
with this is what we do.
When I wake up, it never, ever enters my mind that
I'm so far removed from having a debate with myself
of if I'm gonna run, that I know it might be hard
for some people to hear, but like there is never an inkling
of doubt of like, I'm not doing this, I'm tired,
I'm going back to bed.
I just think, is it rain?
Oh, it's raining, damn it, this is gonna suck.
I hate running in the rain.
But I'm doing it.
And I mean, even when I had the shoulder surgery,
it was like a blizzard outside.
And my wife's like, "Dude, you can't even see outside,
it's like a white out, what are you doing?"
I'm like, "I gotta do this."
She's like, "We have a fucking wood way treadmill,
go in the basement."
I'm like, "I feel like."
Does it count?
I don't mind running on the treadmill sometimes,
but I was like.
Isn't that how you fucked up your shoulder,
your knee, or something like that?
Yes, yes.
I had a damaged shoulder for years that was just like,
it bothered me, but not terribly.
I fell down and like wrenched behind me.
I mean, I fell so awkwardly as I was like turning
around a corner, the people in the guard shack
and where we live must have been like,
"What is this guy doing?"
There were no cars, no nothing.
And I just tore everything, labrum, rotator cuff,
I had gone and the guy was like,
"Oh, you need everything fixed."
And I was like, "All right, we'll do it in April
after the Boston Marathon."
And after like a week or so of trying to get through this,
I just called him I was like,
"Dude, I can't take it anymore, I come in tomorrow."
And he was like, it was a Friday,
he said, "Come in Tuesday."
And I went in Tuesday, and got it done.
But to my point about the mindset thing is like,
if you can just prove to yourself that you can do this,
get up and run every day for 10 days,
see if you can get 10 days, 'cause if you get 10,
20 sounds good too.
And then the next thing is someone was like,
I work with a brand called Rona clothing brand.
They have a 30 day 5K show.
He's like, yeah, "We're doing this, you wanna do it?"
I was like, "Yeah, I've been doing it for like five years.
I'll one up, y'all do 15K."
Yeah, that's just a subset of what I'm already doing
every day, and have been forever.
Yeah, but I think that even that as a starter
for some people is like, I know Goggins puts up challenges
all the time, and he's someone that I respect his mindset,
and I also respect his humility in that like
he doesn't profess to know everything,
but he knows what he does know.
And that's kind of how I feel about the running.
It's like I know what I know, I'm not the best,
but I know that you're gonna get my best when I show up,
we're going, like you're gonna have to kill me to beat me,
if it comes down to like my choice,
I'm gonna empty the tank.
I think that the mindset stuff is you have to prove
to yourself that you can do it because like you said,
I have nothing special, I'm every man,
I'm an average athlete at best,
I played division three football and hockey.
I was like, Jack of all trades master of none,
I was just willing to do whatever I had to do
to stick around, and be on the team.
If they needed me to fight, I'll be like, okay, I'll fight.
But your advantage, or your superpower
is your mental game.
Like I hear somebody who really understands
the idea of non-negotiables, like you're able to commit
to something, and follow through with action.
So it's not about VO2 Max or anything like that.
I couldn't tell you any of those metrics.
It's it's just about like,
do you ever wear a heart rate monitor by the way?
Mh mh.
Like okay.
Sometimes my watch measures it,
and it'll put it on Strava, and people will be like,
dude heart rate of I don't know, 185, blah, blah, blah.
I'm like, oh, that was my heart rate,
I didn't even know it was.
Mario doesn't make you strap one on once in a while?
That's the best thing about Mario,
he knows who he is dealing with, he knows his.
But the point being like,
that's really like the engine behind all of this,
is like that mental discipline, and that's a muscle
just like anything else, that's something you can train,
just like you can train your running, or your cycling,
or what have you.
100%, I wish that that was the one thing
that people take away from this is that,
I think of myself as just dopey guy,
who's made a shitload of mistakes like anyone else.
Same insecurity, same fear, the difference is
I'm not letting that control me anymore.
Fear is such a powerful emotion.
When I moved to New York City,
I mean, when I was in high school, it was like,
my kids asked me the other day, "Dad, did you ever get
in a fight when you were a kid?"
I was like, "Did we get into a fight?
I probably had 200 fights in school."
And to think about, it is insane,
'cause there hasn't probably been three fights
in my kid's school in like the last 10 years.
But it's just such a different world, but the point is like,
everyone feels nervous about those kind of interactions,
but the minute that people think
you're too nervous to do it, is the minute that
they'll always want to have a problem with you,
like classic bully shit.
So in high school, I realized I'm so afraid of this,
and this is an ever present danger of growing up
in this kind of like inner city, like blue collar thing.
It's like, there's a lot of people dealing
with a lot of shit.
And it's like, you don't wanna be the target
of someone else's shit.
Like half the kids I was in elementary school
with were then in the prison.
So it was like you're with these kids
who some of them have very difficult households,
and situations, so you're in this dangerous situation.
Now, I was just like attack it
from a very practical standpoint in that I just went
to the sum boxing club where literally like John Ruiz,
the heavyweight champion of the world was in there training.
Boxing gym is like the most intimidating,
but also the most welcoming place in the world.
Anyone that has the guts that come in,
and wants to train, let's go.
If you approve that, you can come back
after getting get punched in the face, you're good.
'Cause that's the ultimate test, is when you get hit back,
holy shit, do I wanna do this?
This isn't fun, I can't see, I think my nose is broken,
and that doesn't take much.
So I started boxing in high school,
and scared to death every time, like I said to you,
when I pulled in here, I was like had that anxiety feeling
of like, "Oh, I'm gonna spar with this guy who is a killer."
And it's just similar emotions, the point is that emotion,
whether it's tied to fear, or telling your story to someone,
or a big meeting in work, or a speaking gig,
the emotions are the same.
If you can learn to deal with those emotions,
and harness that everyone feels them the same,
but the people who are successful learn to harness that,
and use it as their own tool,
whether it's get them more ready,
or get them to perform at a higher level,
and you see it all the time, you don't think that Tom Brady
is scared to death in the fourth quarter,
when they're trailing in the Super Bowl?
The difference is he's feeling the nerves,
but he's like, let's go, he's using this like.
Right, you have a strategy to channel that
into something productive as opposed to letting
it capsize you.
And the boxing for me was my outlet
that I was scared every time I went, every fight,
every sparring session, but I kept going because
I don't wanna be controlled by fear, and it served me
in a lot of ways in life, including dealing with addiction,
'cause when you're about to go through withdrawals,
and entering into this like uphill battle that is recovery,
you're like, I don't wanna do it,
let me just put it off for a week.
If you have these tools, you're equipped to deal
with all these different challenges, and look, it doesn't
make you immune to mistakes,
you're gonna make mistakes, but hopefully,
if you have these mental tools,
and I think you can continue like you said,
increase the strength of that mental tool,
it is mindset by setting realistic goals for yourself,
and working towards them, maybe it's like I said,
a mile a day, two miles a day, but the boxing
was a good analogy for me in that, I just kept doing it,
and kept dealing 'cause nothing else seemed
even remotely scary to me as getting in a fight.
And boxing for the New York Athletic Club, even as an adult,
I was like, "Man, why am I doing this?
This is so scary."
But I'm doing it anyway.
That's it right there.
Well, awesome to talk to you, man.
I trust that like is Berlin the next race
that you're going for right now?
Yeah, I'm going to Berlin, September 25th.
Two weeks later, I'll do Chicago.
See if I can do a quick turn.
You make any predictions on Berlin, Chicago double?
You know what?
I believe that if you speak your truth,
and aren't afraid to like say even ambitious goals,
like, hey, hold me accountable.
I think that I could run 2:26 there, I think that 2:25,
I wouldn't be like, "Oh my God, what happened?
Did I cut the course?"
2:25 on the right day.
When I ran 1:10 in Nashville,
if I feel like that on a marathon course,
especially like a fast course, I don't think that
that's unrealistic at all.
And yeah, I would love to be able to set a new PR
in the marathon this year at 51.
And then, like I said, two weeks later, I'll do Chicago.
I have much lower expectations there,
I just wanna win my age group.
And then in March I'll do the final marathon major in Tokyo.
Wow, wow.
Seems crazy to me 'cause when I started running,
I was like, I just wanted to finish the marathon,
or qualify for Boston.
And now to look on my bookshelves
when I have a Zoom call or something,
and see hardware from Boston, New York, London,
I'm like, it's so funny because you wanna win this stuff,
and then you have it, and you're like, next.
That stuff, it's like I said with the mountain,
like you get there, and you're like, I climbed Everest,
I wonder if I can climb every highest peak,
and whatever like next challenge is.
I wish that I would do a better job of appreciating
the process more than I do, and each accomplishment
a little bit longer as opposed to like,
all right, what's next?
We'll build that into your non-negotiables.
No, you're right, you brought up some really good points
that I've got a lot of things to reflect on.
It wasn't my intention there,
I was just here to have fun with you.
I've had a great time.
I'm inspired by everything
that you're doing, man, I think it's super cool.
I'm so glad we have this opportunity to sit down together.
For people that are, are watching or listening,
check out Ken stuff on Strava, he's for real,
you can see the paces that he's throwing down,
He's not fucking around right now.
And we'll be cheering for you my brother,
and come back, and share some more with me sometime.
This has just been fun.
Yeah, man, next time I come back,
I've got some crazy prison stories
that are gonna make your head spin.
Yeah, all right, we'll just do three hours
of prison stories.
(Ken laughs)
'Cause there is no shortage.
Thank you for having me, man.
Honestly, I really appreciate it.
Congratulations on all your successes, I love it.
I love seeing people like make a career out of doing things
that are actually helpful, and make them happy,
and I'm sure you don't feel like you're working.
It can feel like work,
it's still work,
it's like you prepare for it like you prepare for a race.
You wanna create the environment for the best experience,
and that doesn't happen without some effort,
but mostly joy.
And it's such a privilege to be able
to meet people like yourself.
It certainly comes through.
It certainly reflects in the show, man, it's awesome.
And thank you again for having me, I appreciate you.
Cool, peace.
Peace.
(upbeat music)